hi i'm sarah and here on the manager
farms channel today it's upcycle monday
which means we're going to be making a
solar powered drip irrigation system
for free just using recyclables
the first thing you need for this
project is a one liter completely free
of any labels at least as much as
possible
and then you make a cut about at this
line here
first things first for any project
especially with little ones around it's
better to not have them with arms
reached when you could be cutting
something
so i'm going to pass them off to his
uncle
yes
now you just need a two liter bottle
again as freeze-label as possible can't
get everything all the time
cut about here
so now that we have all of our parts cut
up and ready it's time to install the
watering system into our plants it's
important to note that this is not to
replace your regular watering system but
just to help when it gets hot and your
plants are going to need the extra
moisture
so leave the cap on
so the water does not absorb into the
dirt
that's for the other parts
so i think i want to install it right
about over here i miss the plants but
yet not too close to any one particular
root structure
and you're going to want to go a couple
inches down because you want to get some
of the base into the dirt so it doesn't
really loosen up too easy
and because we're not forecasted to have
any rain in the next couple days we're
going to add some water into it
i'd say about there
never waste
got some extra water you might as well
just splash it around
any thirsty plants that might be nearby
now the cool thing about this irrigation
system
is that we then place this piece of
plastic over the water
and down a little bit
so as the heat heats up the water
it causes water to evaporate the water
evaporates and condenses and goes down
the sides of the container back into the
soil watering all the root systems at
once and that extra time of thirst
thank you for joining us and have a
great day
[Applause]
now remember if we all gave up our lawns
for gardens there'd be no more hunger in
america
good boy
because i am not good at this do i have
to do it like right here
okay hold on
[Applause]
hi today on the maybe farms channel
oh i messed up
i go then you go okay
okay
is it ready okay
hi i'm sarah president of lot number
seven and today on the miami farms
channel we're going to be doing a solar
powered
dammit carl i forgot what size of all is
this
one liter
now we're ready
hi i'm sarah and today on the management
farms channel